I want to start today with an explosive
confrontation that took place during
another one of these Republican Senate
hearings this particular confrontation
involved unhinged Republican senator
Mark Wayne Mullen uh as well or with or
alongside or up against I guess you
would say Teamsters president Sean
O'Brien Teamsters of course a union
Republicans tend not to like unions
Republicans love to frame unions as sort
of like mob entities and the guys or
gals who run unions as as mob bosses and
we've seen that narrative for a while
the big Continuing Story since
Republicans have taken over control of
the house is the humiliating face
planting and self-destructive nature of
these hearings the hearings that
Republicans have organized and this is
happening in the house and the Senate uh
on big and and crossover hearings as
well
um on big Tech on weaponization of the
justice system or whatever the case may
be and even when it is not Republicans
who organize the hearing they still find
new ways to humiliate themselves so
let's take a look at this video Bernie
Sanders was sort of trying to uh
officiate this thing and it is the
latest Brazen attempt uh by Republicans
to attack labor which is what they love
to do you talk about CEO those that are
making all this money
and what do you make Mr O'Brien well I'm
glad you asked that question yeah I know
what you make because in 2019 your
salary was
um what is this 193 000 I'm sure you've
got some pay raises since then yeah
so basically like the same salary as
Mark Wayne Mullen gets as a senator
that's an interesting thing a little
higher PS driver the feeder driver makes
35 000 a year and what do you bring
that's inaccurate hold on a second
that's inaccurate right here stay faxed
that's an act average UPS feeder driver
makes 35 000 if you don't know your
facts and maybe use I know because I
negotiate so I say I say one thing to
you what do you bring for that salary
what do I bring yeah what do you what
job have you committed or have you have
you uh uh started what job have you
created one job other than sucking a
paycheck
out of some other by somebody else that
you want to say that you're trying to
provide because you're forced so
remember the narrative here is
unions are oppressive the people who run
them take money in exchange for nothing
other than forcing the workers to pay
union dues and we would all be better
off if there were no unions and the
workers had a direct relationship with
the companies now of course we know that
that's not the case and we know that as
a result of the unions and being able to
collectively bargain in this way the
workers actually end up earning more on
average all else being equal but that's
not the story that Republicans like to
tell about unions
don't tell me I'm out of
linear statement yeah because you don't
know yes I did what yeah older tough guy
but don't sit there and tell me I'm out
of line
set it up
he made a statement you asked the
question I didn't ask a question you did
it I did a question you asked the
question
let him answer Israel you may think it's
rhetorical it founded to be like a
question let him answer the question I'm
not yielding my time to him so if you're
going to let me keep my time that's fine
you'll have your time let him you ask a
question he has no right to answer that
as far as my salary goes my salary if
you follow me around I walk I actually
look at this building I bet you I work
more hours than you do twice as many
hours that's impossible but no that is
that's true sir
greedy CEOs like yourself accountable
you call me a greedy oh yeah you are you
want to attack my salary I'll Attack
y'all what do I make what did you make
when you owned your company well I made
my company I kept my salary down at
about 50 000 a year because I'm better
now this we all know this game this is
so just I kept my salary down and of
course as CEO Mark Wayne Mullen made
tens of millions of dollars towards his
net worth from non-salary compensation
typical move maybe he thinks nobody else
knows that but we know that game said
every penny into it okay all right you
mean you hid money no I didn't oh oh
hold on a second okay so there's a
couple different things here that I
think are important to mention
um one of those things is the general
idea that Republicans want to put out
there and I don't even want to say that
Republicans believe they may not believe
it as we know a lot of this stuff is
just performance the idea that they put
out there
is that rather than a tool or an
infrastructure that allows workers to
organize and to pool their negotiating
strength in order to obtain better
salary and benefits from a situation in
which an individual worker has
disproportionately little power right
that's essentially what the union allows
workers to do in order to get higher
salary and better benefits the union
they frame as almost like a leech that
just collects dues forcibly which by the
way often is not the case that you're
forced into the Union into pay dues in
fact sometimes it's the opposite where
even if you refuse to pay the dues the
union still represents you but that's a
detail and depends on the union and it
takes away value the idea is oh the
workers come out with less because not
only do they end up having to uh pay the
dues they don't even get a higher salary
or better benefits we know that that's
not the case I mean it's been studied
endlessly and we know that's not the
case so that's that's number one and
then number two with all of these
Republicans some personal hypocrisy is
not far behind and it is not lost on me
and I hope it's not lost on you the
irony or the absurdity
of Mark Wayne Mullen calling the
Teamsters president with a low
six-figure salary the greedy CEO when
the entire point of the teamsters is to
negotiate better pay and benefits for
for tons of different workers when Mark
Wayne mullen's net worth and his assets
exploded by tens of millions of dollars
tens of millions of dollars over the
last few years so they are pathetic yes
they are hypocrites yes but they also
have to lie about unions now I am not an
unreasonable person when it comes to
unions I recognize that there are lots
of small businesses where a union
doesn't really make sense and I am not
someone who goes around and says every
business should be unionized that's just
not my view I've not come to believe
that that's the best thing but when
you're talking about these organizations
with tons of workers electricians
electricians union trade unions for
particular companies UPS Etc
the Dynamics of those companies and the
sheer scale of those companies are such
that there has to be some mechanism for
all of these employees who have shared
interests to be able to pool their power
because remember when there are thirty
thousand sixty thousand employees or
whatever the case may be one person if
forced to negotiate individually has
relatively little power because they can
just be excluded or pushed to the side
or their their influence minimized when
the negotiation is happening
collectively that is a very different
situation and it puts large companies in
the position
of having to really come to the table
not necessarily in good faith but at
least willing to negotiate in a real way
so very interesting exchange and shows
the continued hostility towards labor
from the modern Republican Party
Republicans are now going to investigate
the January 6th investigation what yeah
we knew they would do it the last
Congress saw the House of
Representatives January 6th committee
that was a committee which investigated
the Trump riots Republicans for a long
time have been saying the committee is
the problem the committee has committed
wrongdoing and now as expected there is
going to be an investigation of the
investigation NBC news reports
Republicans launched an investigation
into the January 6th committee
that examined the riot Congressman Barry
Loudermilk from Georgia will lead the
investigation and was accused by The
house's former January 6th panel of
giving tours of the capital in the days
leading up to the riot so individuals
whose connection to the riots
is at minimum
raising some red flags
are going to be doing the investigating
into the very committee that looked at
some of their own actions this is an
infinite regression to some degree but
it is also maybe one of the most bad
faith investigations that Republicans
want to take on the article goes on to
say many House Republicans were vocal
critics since the creation of the
January 6 committee yeah we know
uh the inquiry seems to make good on
lawmaker campaign Trail vows to
investigate the investigators Now
understand this will go nowhere this is
going to go absolutely nowhere I know
that I get some of these emails from the
right and see some comments on the
YouTube channel about oh we're gonna put
we're gonna put Adam Schiff in prison
for that January 6 committee Jamie
raskins gonna be locked up for the Gen
no they're not nobody's going to be
locked up it was a completely reasonable
well-organized well it was actually one
of the best investigative Endeavors that
I've seen the House of Representatives
undertake uh in at least a decade but
they need to Virtue signal they need to
show that we are going to do the thing
and it'll sort of end with a Fizz rather
than a bang and nothing will happen a
couple of other notes about this CNN
report some additional details House
Republicans plot new January 6th probes
despite internal back flash over Kevin
McCarthy giving Tucker Carlson footage
so this is the background to Republicans
saying we're going to investigate that
January 6th Committee in the background
Republicans are only raising new reasons
why they should be the ones investigated
and most recently it is Kevin McCarthy
handing over previously unreleased
footage from the January 6th
Insurrection Riot call it what you want
to Tucker Carlson to Fox News propaganda
Tucker Carlson we now know of course
that Tucker Carlson turned that around
and used the footage to try to claim
falsely by the way that the entire story
we were told about January 6 was wrong
even many Republicans in responding to
Tucker Carlson's bogus narrative that he
has played out on National Television I
believe it was Monday and Tuesday of
this week even many Republicans have
said Tucker's conclusions Tucker's
narrative based on the footage that he
aired doesn't actually follow from the
footage so this is the latest thing it
will probably end you know to people
like you and I we see this stuff and we
say wow humiliating endless resources
spent The Virtue signaling and the mouth
flapping and the entire thing and of
course they come up with nothing it's
like Durham Trump waiting around for
months if not years Durham Durham's
going to expose all the things Democrat
nothing came of it nothing came of it
and that's why these investigations are
very loudly announced and then they end
with a Fizz because there's really
nothing there if anything we need a new
January 6th committee investigating the
alleged and arguable Republican cover-up
of January 6th that even includes these
recent things over the last few months
what will actually happen uh as the
day-to-day uh and what confrontations
were will there be or what would the
hearings be like we'll just have to wait
and see but I am not a betting man but I
would be willing to bet here nothing
substantive comes of the investigation
into the investigation if you disagree
with me if you think that the January
6th committee did something wrong or
whatever the case may be let me know in
a comment let me know in an email I'd be
interested in hearing from you
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bon
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a 12
month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman 15 for 15 off the link is down
below
the David Pacman show is a viewer and
listener funded program and the easiest
way to support the work that we do every
day is to sign up for a membership at
joinpakman.com not only do we do an
extra show every day for our members we
provide you with commercial free access
in either video or audio format to the
Daily podcast as well as that bonus show
and we make it all available to you
hours before the shows are publicly
launched we also do members only Town
Hall events and we have a member-only
sound board with a lot of the clips that
I play globalished internationalist okay
yeah you know those
um all of that is available when you
become a member at joinpakman.com and
you can finalize our anti-celebration of
last weekend's CPAC
by using the coupon code CPAC trash
that's all one word lowercase uppercase
whatever but it is all one word CPAC
trash to get yourself a neat little
discount off of the cost of a membership
at joinpakman.com I am going to play for
you something quite stunning and this
goes to you know we've talked before on
the program about the
pseudo-intellectual and
anti-intellectual movement and this has
come overwhelmingly from the American
right wing although sometimes the left
engages in it as well and one of the
things that has been a staple one of the
aspects to this that has been a stable
from the right
is that thinking too much actually isn't
that good formal education is little
more than liberal indoctrination and so
we shouldn't even really be praising or
seeking out intellectualism but there's
another aspect to this which is making
nonsense people out to be
intellectuals that they are not and I
have an example of this that is quite
stunning uh Tucker Carlson introduced an
interview that he did with I guess
former actor and now YouTuber Russell
Brand Tucker Carlson refers to Russell
Bland Russell Brand as a public
intellectual now I know I know that will
come as a shock to many of you
but what is stunning is that then
Russell Brand proceeds to rant
completely unintelligibly about kovid
for five minutes and Tucker just sits
there looking dazed take a look at this
there there is a lot that I want to talk
about from this clip let's listen so as
we told you we sat down yesterday with
Russell Brand the comedian actor and now
frankly kind of a public intellectual
for about an hour and a half on our show
Tucker Carlson today we want to share
more of it tonight in particular Brands
spent a lot of time thinking about and
telling us about the thinking lockdowns
yeah and the point Russell has thought
about it a lot of them was maybe the
clearest explanation we have heard of
what we've just lived through here it is
laughs
[Music]
kovid provided a lens through which we
could scrutinize the Machinery of power
and how the intentions and agenda of
Power are able to play out coalesce and
let's call it conspire when a crisis
occurs now remember there's two things
here that might trick right Wingers into
thinking that this is deep thought one
is that for the American audience
you know where I'm going Russell Brand
speaks with a British accent and that
actually is quite an effective tool this
this applies both to left and right I
hate to say into making it sound like
someone is actually speaking quite
intelligently uh the other thing is that
he is only feeding back to a lot of the
these right Wingers the things they
already believe our attendancy a
globalist tendency to increase
surveillance a big Tech appetite to
capture data and a comparable appetite
within government converges the Great
American comedian George Carlin used to
say there is no need for conspiracy
where interests converge it seems that
even if it's Advent it was a legitimate
crisis and I certainly wouldn't make any
contention around that it was
opportunistically handled in order to
enhance regulation and control at a time
where regulation and control are
increasingly difficult to implement as
people are more suspicious of
institutional power so in a sense the
best way to understand covid I believe
is to take covid out of it it and look
at how the institutions both ignore
covid to understand Covenant government
behaved around it pretend almost like
there was no covet and then be like well
none of this stuff made sense if you
remove covet from it right well but
there was covet how did they benefit how
did they utilize it what narratives did
they uh disseminate and which narrative
did they control and curtail even with
the recent text messages from our health
minister at that time Matt Hancock you
can explicitly see it was exploited oh
no we need to scare people is there any
way high net worth individuals can get
into the country all these conversations
but many people that are cynical about
the behavior of the powerful believed
were happening were indeed happening the
way that natural immunity was discussed
proved to be true I.E their natural
immunity is effective they probably
understood earlier than they admitted
that natural immunity was effective and
for reasons that no the use of the word
probably
it be and what could be the reason that
that solution to kovid was prioritized
over a non-madetizable is there anyone
involved in the situation well one
interesting aspect to that would be the
dramatically higher death rate of people
who got covered rather than unvaccinated
versus people who got coveted vaccinated
that would be one interesting reason why
you would prioritize the vaccination
program that has a profit motive let's
look at the data and let you know so
what it was just revelatory like the
apocalypse always will and remember
Tucker Carlson hasn't said a word we're
two minutes in hey the apocalypse is
revelation of all what was always there
corruption convergence of interests
alliances this is not conspiratorial the
moot recycle of economic interests and
the ordinary movements of the power if
people can uh honor one another and
towards one another in good faith and
recognize that anybody if they're like
let's hold debater between like that
I've sort of felt a little bit around me
even for coming here I feel like it used
to just be normal that someone in your
family would be a conservative and
someone in your family would be liberal
on and someone in your family would be
socialist and someone in your family
would be trans and someone in your
family would be gay and different races
are coming together is this part of who
we are and if it isn't the part of who
we are it's certainly okay so this goes
on and on and on and on and on okay so a
couple different things here first of
all most of the things that Russell is
saying actually just aren't true and if
you really kind of dissect all of this
different stuff you see there's really
nothing there but I want to zoom out and
talk about this this the framing that
Tucker Carlson gave of saying that
Russell Brand is now he's a public
intellectual quite frankly I think it
was is what Tucker Carlson said now what
do we mean by a public intellectual many
of us can imagine sort of like the
academic intellectual right this is
someone who and I'm this is this is the
caricature and I understand I'm playing
into the caricature but the idea would
be
the academic intellectual is someone who
if you put a camera in front of them for
a TV show they're not really good at
explaining their ideas and they're not
concise and they go on and on and they
talk about their work and their thoughts
in a way that is not relatable to the
average person and they are sometimes
seen as as uh um maybe Elite or
condescending to the average person
right so public intellectual would be
it's someone who is well known and an
intelligent you know learned person from
an academic uh a pedigree of sorts but
who is also contributing their knowledge
in the sort of more popular culture I
guess we would say and is recognized
both on the academic side but also on
the non-academic and sort of like media
side and by members of society in
general so obviously by that definition
Russell Brand is not a public
intellectual but the bigger story here
for me is I've said before you know
sometimes Marjorie Taylor green will
rant somewhere and I will say to you all
a lot of a lot of the American right
wing sees her as a thinking person
and Lauren bobert will rant or you know
Ted Cruz will make some statement about
a legal precedent during a hearing and I
will say there are a lot of people in
the U.S on the right who see that as
what it means to be a thinker and of
course Russell Brand is very far from
really what I would consider to be
public intellectuals now public
intellectuals today do look and sound a
lot different than at times past so I'll
give you some examples of people that I
do think are sort of public
intellectuals one that comes to mind and
I was just recent listening to some of
his podcasts and and that's why he's on
my mind
Cal Newport Cal Newport is a PhD
computer scientist who teaches at
Georgetown he's been on the show before
who writes both for academic audiences
and for General audiences about the
socio-cultural impacts of Technology
uh and and so many other things he's
written articles that would be really
for an academic audience and he's also
written great popular books like deep
work and a world without email and
others that to me makes a lot more sense
as like a modern public intellectual and
when you when you listen to Cal's
podcast you realize wow this is a very
different thing than Russell Brand
Cal doesn't have a British accent I will
mention that other examples maybe Jared
Diamond someone who
has done a ton of academic work and and
really deep field work and also has
written books uh for popular consumption
this one I I'm less sure but someone
like kazuo ishiguro the British Japanese
British writer Salman Rushdie comes to
mind
um Camille Paglia even if you don't like
her views hard to argue that that's not
you know when we talk about a public
intellectual today that's what we're
talking about Daniel Dennett would be
another example so anyway it's an
interesting thing I don't know if Tucker
is is serious when he says Russell Brand
is a public intellectual or not
um but it's a very interesting phrase to
hear amuse particularly when the right
has spent a long time sort of deriding
the value of public intellectuals until
they found someone they can try to pass
off as one in order to try to make some
kind of political Point interesting an
interesting uh use of that term this is
a crazy story I thought this was fake
when I first heard about it Lauren
bobert is about to be a grandmother
now I know I know you're saying wait
Lauren bobert how old is she Lauren
bobert is 36 years old and she is about
to be a grandmother because her teenage
son is going to be having a baby next
month and listen there are a lot of
cultural differences between
different parts of the country there's
no doubt about that uh and it is much
less common in parts of the country more
liberal parts of the country uh to see
something like this celebrated and I'll
tell you why in a moment with some
statistics but Lauren bobert is
celebrating it Lauren bobert is acting
like it's a good thing that she as a
former teen mom is now going to be a
grandmother thanks to her son becoming a
teen dad let's take a look at this big
announcement from Lauren bober this is
this is uh there's a lot here okay I'm a
mom of four boys
and I've said many times Jason and I we
are raising our four boys to be men okay
before liberals teach them to be women
okay
[Applause]
but I leaned over and I asked my husband
if it was appropriate to announce this
here today so I'm going to tell you all
for the first time in a public setting
that not only am I a mom of four boys
but come April
I will be a Gigi to a grand new a brand
new grandson
wow
even this crowd is sort of like okay
yeah kind of like a muted reaction I
have to say
[Applause]
so excited to welcome this new life into
our family
now any of you who have young children
who are
giving life
there are some questions that pop up
there's some there are a hell of a lot
of questions popping up based on what
she's saying that's for sure fear that
arises
now my son when I approached him and
told him Tyler I'm going to be a 36 year
old grandmother
he said well didn't you make granny a 36
year old granny said yes I did right he
said well then it's hereditary
nice that's pretty interesting actually
there's actually a lot there and here's
an additional clip again where Lauren
bobert she talks about
she she talks about this like it's a
good thing okay and she wants to make it
a cultural thing she wants to talk about
how great is it that the culture of life
in red States leads to a high teen birth
rate and you know there's something
special about rural conservative
communities yes there is
they value life if you look at teen
pregnancy rates throughout the nation
well they're the same in rural and urban
areas however abortion rates are higher
in urban areas and Teen Mom rates are
higher in rural conservative areas
because we understand the preciousness
of the life that is about
to be born wow so a few different things
now I don't want to make this into a
cultural critique there is a cultural
critique here to be made without a doubt
okay but by their own claims by their
own claims it's not really clear to me
that these really are the pro-life
values as exhibited by teens who get
pregnant in red States not seeking
abortions I don't think that that's the
great thing to celebrate that Lauren
bobert is making it out to be because
the most important thing to look at here
is how do the kids of teen parents do in
life
and the children of young mothers do
notably less well in life this is not
about saying Lauren bobert's grandkid
deserves to do poorly the grandkid I
would consider a victim in this
situation it's that the kid is not being
well set up to succeed when you look at
outcomes of all sorts and types poverty
How likely to graduate high school all
of these different things you see the
ideal outcomes when the parents or
usually what they're looking at is the
mother
is at least 25 years old and then from
20 to 25 year old moms you see less good
outcomes and then when the mom is under
20 you see absolutely the worst outcomes
and the the difference is significant
now this isn't about saying a 19 year
old can't be a good mom of course that's
not the case this isn't about saying if
you're 18 and you have a kid you love
the kid any less or whatever it is not
about that but the younger the mother is
the higher the rate of poverty the less
likely the child is to graduate high
school you get the picture but then we
get not only to the weirdness of
celebrating this when we know that
statistically it's actually not a good
thing the hypocrisy here is that the way
to prevent this if you think it's not a
good thing now Lauren bobert seems to be
celebrating it okay there is a cultural
aspect of this if you think this isn't a
good thing
the way to prevent it is of course safe
legal access to abortion we know that
but teaching comprehensive sex education
that reduces teen pregnancy it's been
studied widely comprehensive sex ed
reduces teen pregnancy Lauren bobert is
against that Lauren bobert recently
voted against funding that and so there
is that aspect to it as well which is
she is partially to blame certainly her
movement is to blame for the creation of
the circumstances that got us here in
the first place and by the way Lauren
bobert also says that children should be
forced to wait until they're age 21 to
make decisions about just even what
their gender expression is going to be
but having a baby at 17 is a great thing
and is fine that's also another one of
these stunning hypocrisies so listen
there when we talk about different
different American cultures
um this is one aspect that is very very
different and to what degree some of
what she's doing is a rationalization
because the cake is baked for lack of a
better term I don't know
uh but it is really really wacky stuff
if you want to see Lauren bobert deliver
this news to this titillated crowd all
of these clips that I played will be on
our Instagram which you can find by
searching Instagram for David Pacman
show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
Alana Newhouse who's the founder and
editor-in-chief of tablet magazine we're
going to be talking about a term
brokenism which I think is super
interesting and it sort of puts a
different perspective on what you know
maybe Alana in our program we often see
as like a left right political divide
only and that's the analysis we make and
we sort of don't go any further you talk
about brokenism and Status quoism talk a
little bit about how you first thought
of this framework and what you mean by
it
um sure so uh two years ago I wrote a
piece
um called Everything Is Broken
um in it I tried to articulate what felt
to me like an experience that not only I
was having but a lot of my readers were
having or a lot of people who I knew
were having which was the sense that a
lot of the institutions in American life
and society that we have to interact
with whether that's our kids schools or
our health insurance companies
um with or the IRS felt like they were
not functioning properly they felt
broken
um in the wake of that piece I got a
tremendous response to it it was really
incredibly gratifying and one of the
greatest parts of it was that I ended up
getting emails from a bunch of people
who became regular correspondents with
me
and one of them became a friend and his
name is Ryan and I talk about this in
the beginning of the follow-up essay on
brokenism where at One Moment Ryan
looked at me and said you know I don't
even know what I am I don't know if I'm
a Republican or a Democrat or if I'm a
liberal or conservative all I know is
that I believe in Europe in the basic
premise of your piece which is that
things feel broken and so I guess I
believe in Brokenness
and that kind of
um articulated an idea for me that I
thought
was very clarifying because it felt to
me like that actually was a thing that
people believed from all over the
Spectrum
um and so it I tried to write a second
piece that articulated what I thought a
Brokenness perspective on the world
um entailed you know sometimes when I'll
have a more detailed conversation with
folks who have this general idea that
there's a lot of things that aren't
working but they might identify as being
on the political left or on the
political right one of the things I've
experienced is that when you really get
details from them about what are the
ways in which some of these systems
aren't working and what's your instinct
about the solution it seems to align
much more closely with what we would be
considered a left-wing View
now that may be my bias in who I'm
talking to but very often it will be the
the Revelation I have that there's a lot
of discontent with many systems but a
lot of people don't seem to realize that
the solutions they are gravitating
towards are actually more aligned with
one side of political Spectrum than the
other and that's sort of like a concern
to me that people are aren't
acknowledging that do do you experience
the same thing when you talk to some of
these folks or is my view maybe partial
or biased
um what I I think I probably experienced
something a little different from you
but what I guess I would say is is that
one of the things that people talk to me
about is not only the solutions that
they're looking for but also the
diagnosis of the problem and if if in a
funny way if I could say
um what I think might be the case even
maybe for the people that you're talking
to yes is that the solutions that
they're grasping for no matter what part
of the spectrum they come from ends up
being solutions that would be associated
with the left but the diagnosis of the
problem
sounds a lot like people from the right
um and that's also interesting right
because then we can have a conversation
that can be generative where we can say
oh okay so maybe I come from the left
but I can talk to somebody from the
right because actually what we could
agree on is what's causing some of these
problems even if what we just even if we
disagree on how we would what we would
do to replace them
and that to me part of the reason why I
set out this different way of seeing
things is because also I was trying to
get people out of their entrenched teams
and get them talking to each other and
finding the
um the areas of the landscape on which
they might agree
one of the things that I've experienced
at the anecdotal personal level when
interviewing former extremists like KKK
Neo-Nazi types Etc is that they all tell
a very similar story of the
circumstances that made them vulnerable
to getting pulled into these movements
in the first place and it's a lot of
things that weren't working it was a lot
of broken things that that were going on
is this a bro I mean not everybody
becomes a KKK member obviously or a
Neo-Nazi but there seems to be a
radicalizing effect of a lot of these
things that just aren't working for
people is that accurate
um I think it is
um and I think the people who study
extremism might find uh overlapping
themes or uh
events in um in some of what I write
about
um and you know it's part of what's a
challenge here is
a friend of mine actually wrote and said
you know Alana I sort of agree with you
I see what you're saying but I mean come
on is it really mono causal why how did
all of these institutions get broken at
the same time how is that even possible
so many of them started at different
times
and so of course the answer is quite
clear which is technology like we did
have one thing happen
um and if you actually look back to the
Industrial Revolution
this exact same thing happened in
society
when you have an economic Revolution
that changes the means of how we live
it then comprehensively almost in a
Cascade changes all parts of life it
changes religion communication uh the
Postal Service like it changes
everything and as a result we have to
adjust I think the same thing is
happening now these Institute all of our
institutions were faced with the
challenge of needing to embrace and
adjust themselves to new technologies
some of them adjusted better than others
and some of them are breaking under the
pressure
yeah Neil Postman wrote quite a bit
about this in his books uh technopoly
and then also amusing ourselves to death
and there's a sort of structural
argument there about you know in
linguistics there's this idea it's not I
don't know that it's completely
universally accepted but it's it's much
explored that the language you speak
actually impacts your world view to some
degree based both on a combination of
syntax and the culture surrounding it
and the vocabulary the technologies that
we have including social media or
television or whatever actually are
deterministic to some degree about what
issues make it into the news media or
how do we approach problems or whatever
the case may be it's that sort of
argument that would explain the timing I
think of what you're talking about
yes
absolutely so Neil Postman would say
there's really no going back and it's
about how do you try to regulate in
order to harness the parts we want but
to limit the parts that don't work so
well when we think about Solutions do
you agree with that yes I think that
part of the um you know in this
interview I've talked a lot about the
Brokenness perspective but part of what
I tried to do with the essay was also
articulate the other perspective the
sort of Warring perspective which I also
find incredibly compelling which is the
belief in what's what exists and the
belief that what exists may or may not
uh need some reforming or need some
tweaking but that you simply don't throw
whole institutions or systems out the
window especially when those systems
um are
are the the basket for people's needs
um sometimes in their safety and their
livelihoods
um
status quoists believe that we need to
work very very hard at fixing our
current institutions
in a way there's a I think an incredibly
inspiring and exciting conversation to
be had if you put those two groups
together because what you get is you say
oh how about instead of fighting
and trying to convince each other to
join sides we're not going to join what
if together we look at the landscape and
we almost assess like do a do an
assessment and say what are the
institutions that need reforming what
are the institutions that need radical
reforming and what are the institutions
that need complete replacement
and let everyone do their part let the
Brokenness look at something and say
this is broken I'm burning it to the
grounds and I'm starting again
and let the status quoists reform what
might actually be salvageable the the
difficulty in that as great as it sounds
is that there is a big divide about
what's worthy of totally being destroyed
and starting from scratch and what needs
to be reforming you mentioned education
last week in a 48-hour period you had
Candace Owens saying the solution to the
U.S being poor at math is breeding for
math skills like the South Koreans do
and then two days later at CPAC she says
we should get rid of the Department of
Education it's like you don't need to
breed you need to teach we have but they
want to but on the left I think we would
not say we need to get rid of the
Department of Education so it seems that
the disagreement would come in which of
which institutions fall under which of
the two categories
and look
and looking to create conversation with
or people who are political rhetoricians
uh that's a challenge that's very
different from my own right I'm actually
looking to create to generate a
conversation that feels fruitful among
at regular people okay and people who
actually are uh maybe uh people who
belong to the same town right um but who
feel differently about the solutions or
differently about the institutions of
their world and they're invested at a
personal and granular level in those
institutions and they are not
grandstanders who are just looking to
make broad points these are people who
actually want to get their hands dirty
they just don't know in what way they
don't know if they're if they want to
get their hands dirty by
completely abandoning their local school
district
because it's become too corrupt right or
by reforming it getting different people
on the board and those are to me those
are decisions that actually do have to
get made at a local level and do have to
get made person by person town by town
community by community
and then I think it generates
friends nationally and maybe even
internationally
super super interesting we've been
speaking with Alana Newhouse who's the
founder and editor-in-chief of tablet
magazine and we'll link to the articles
that we've been sort of talking about in
this conversation Alana really
appreciate your time and insights
thanks so much for having me
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show if you
thought Donald Trump's 2016 promises
about a wall on the southern border that
Mexico would pay for a beautiful new
health care plan ending the
israeli-palestinian conflict and all of
that stuff was unrealistic if you
thought that was far-fetched the stuff
that Trump is increasingly promising if
he were to become president in 2024 is
even more outrageous and it includes
flying cars I know I know I it's it's
truly a stunning thing but that's what
Trump is talking about there's an uh
exclusive Politico article Trump calls
for contest to create futuristic Freedom
cities which says modern cities and
flying cars might sound like the makings
of an episode of The Jetsons where a
fictionalized family flew around in
orbit City for former president Donald
Trump it's the foundation of a new set
of futuristic policy proposals in a
video set to be released Friday Trump
will call for a Quantum Leap in the
American standard of living
he already talked about those Freedom
cities during his CPAC speech which was
pretty unhinged and basically sort of
like a camp for homeless people and
Trump also is talking about
technological elements in another
political article it sort of expands on
the flying car's idea Trump calling for
massive investment in vertical takeoff
and Landing Vehicles also known as
flying cars there is something really
interesting here now first and foremost
the Wright loves to say that the left
promise is unrealistic things the things
the left promises are only unrealistic
insofar as Republicans are unwilling to
actually fund them and insist that
they're not things worth worth uh worth
doing including trying to get everybody
health care or whatever the case may be
one of the really interesting thing
about flying cars is that it's very easy
to visualize it when you talk about well
we're going to
um work hard to change the way that we
power our homes and cars so it's
increasingly from wind and Sun rather
than well listen you I flipped on a
light bulb I don't know it turned on it
doesn't feel that different if the
source changes from being coal to being
solar or whatever the case may be and
because it's less visual it also doesn't
really sound that worthwhile to put any
money into it okay so flying cars
extraordinarily visual the other thing
is that Trump does have this tendency to
get obsessed with something without
really understanding it you might
remember where there were a few speeches
Trump gave I think this was in 2020
where he became focused on going to Mars
even if he called it Nars the United
States will be the first nation to land
an astronaut on ours okay I I remember
it like it was yesterday so Trump does
get fixated on some of this futuristic
stuff as well
um but the flying cars the inclusion of
flying cars is uh is is pretty damn
interesting now flying cars are also
interesting because of the cultural
um importance of flying cars flying cars
have been a sort of microcosm or
emblematic of the future is now here and
if you look at things that were written
uh in the 30s and 40s and certainly you
look at sci-fi in the 50s and 60s lots
of the things that Arthur C Clarke wrote
about 50 years ago have happened
satellites and different things but
flying cars as a sort of ubiquitous
staple of the futuristic Society has not
developed nearly as quickly as some
imagined that it would and there's a lot
of different reasons for that one is if
you're going to have flying cars
they've got to be really really safe and
of course drone technology the sort of
quadcopter type technology
um might offer some of the redundancies
that would be needed for really safe
flying cars but also listen every time
I'm on the highway there's someone in
the fast lane going 57 while on a cell
phone I don't know that I want to put
those people in the air anytime soon and
so until the self-driving technology
really matures flying cars aren't going
to be happening anytime soon but the
inclusion of it is certainly interesting
so a lot of cultural stuff to talk about
when we talk about flying cars and it is
really interesting Trump promising
flying cars between 2025 and 2029 that
is not a realistic promise as I'm sure
most of you realize Tucker Carlson now
seems to be sucking up to failed former
president Donald Trump
after the text messages were revealed in
which Tucker admits to hating Trump
passionately this is very interesting
and I want you to remember that the
number one priority there's really two
priorities for almost all in corporate
media priority number one is ratings and
priority number two is maintaining
access to the most powerful people you
can possibly maintain access to despite
the reality that Tucker Carlson hates
Trump quote passionately
he doesn't want to be on the outs if
Trump is again president of the United
States and so the day after his text
messages attacking Trump were leaked
Tucker Carlson goes on TV and talks
about all of the uh great ideas that
Donald Trump is now proposing take a
listen to this you wouldn't know it from
watching the news media but Donald Trump
is running for president again you know
right so first of all the media isn't
giving Trump enough attention put him in
prison first which of course their plan
um and he's saying things that are
really interesting Trump is saying
interesting things wait but you hate him
passionately and you think he's an idiot
rehashes at all in fact he's come out
with a bunch of proposals that were so
interesting that we thought we
bring them to we've asked foxes Kevin
Cork to bring us the story okay so then
he brings on Kevin Cork and if you
thought that Tucker was being sarcastic
because look I just told you what the
proposals are it includes flying cars if
you thought that Tucker was kidding he's
not this is a serious segment a good
idea often begins with a very single
thought soccer Kevin Cork thanks so much
or babies prettier buildings cleaner
parks
those are achievable goals once would
improve everyone's life
basically Tucker is pretending like
these are reasonable and good ideas so
this is this is very overt Tucker now
having to suck up to Donald Trump and I
don't know what happened behind the
scenes when Tucker's text messages
leaked saying he hates Trump
passionately it's completely plausible
that Tucker and his producer and fox
brass got together and said listen
I get it you hate him I get it listen we
all hate him maybe was even said behind
the scenes but he could be the president
and we want to host a primary debate and
we want to host a presidential debate
and we can't have Trump furious with us
and he's increasingly furious with us so
you got to go and clean this up that's a
completely plausible conversation that
could have happened behind the scenes
these ideas nicer buildings and uh
flying cars and all this different stuff
if it were a Democrat that was proposing
this stuff Tucker Carlson would be doing
his Psychopathic laugh and talking about
how unreasonable and expensive and
unfair to the American taxpayer it would
be to pursue these ideas so don't fall
for it Tucker is trying to clean up his
mess it might actually work Kerry lake
is now starting to do Trump's Dirty Work
she is pounding Ron DeSantis we know
Kerry lake is desperate to be Donald
Trump's Vice President we know that
Kerry lake is
um someone who is willing to do the
Dirty Work and she's so desperate to be
Trump's VP
she can just taste it she is now trying
out by going on TV and attacking Ron
DeSantis here saying why would Ron
DeSantis even consider running for
president he just was reelected he
should really be staying in Florida and
the people of Florida just re-elected
him I'm assuming when they re-elected
him they were hoping he'd stay around
for a while so I mean he's I guess he's
in his 40s he's about 10 years younger
than me he's got a long political future
ahead of him and I think he should
respect that the people just voted him
in as governor and Sir about that term
for the people of of Florida and then he
could obviously run for president but
this is President Trump's turn and so oh
and there's one more clip we haven't
seen Ron DeSantis on the world stage yet
and and you know some of the people that
are surrounding him are kind of the type
of people that we're pushing for war
that were pushing for the endless war
and yeah so a couple different things
first of all I had to look that up
Rhonda santis is 44 years old when I
look at DeSantis I don't see a guy who's
five years older than me I see a guy who
looks 15 years older than me he's
genuinely 44 years old that's stunning
stuff I mean that's an incredible
incredible thing to realize and I'm
gonna have to process that probably a
little bit later because it's Bonkers
but the most important thing to
understand is that the polling data
supports the strategy of encourage
everybody but Ron DeSantis to run
against Trump but try to keep Ron
DeSantis out of the race why when you
look at Republican polling DeSantis is
the only person who pulls well in a
head-to-head matchup against Donald
Trump trump crushes Nikki Haley in a
head-to-head matchup Trump trump really
crushes everybody else uh even people
thinking of running who have not yet
announced but the more people you
include in the polls if you say who
would you support if it was Trump versus
Nikki Haley versus Mike Pompeo versus
Mike Pence versus Tim Scott the more
people you include the better Trump does
because all those other people divide up
support except DeSantis Trump genuinely
would benefit from DeSantis not running
and so here is Carrie Lake trying out
for Trump's VP and certainly willing to
do the Dirty Work will it work to get
her that VP slot axios report we talked
about yesterday says that indeed Trump
is considering her for his running mate
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P here's a really good
question about the Fox News text message
Scandal listen to this
hey David I just want to speak really
briefly about the Fox News Scandal
um I know that you've been covering it
really well
but I just have a comment you know I
think that all this stuff that's coming
out in general simply won't have as big
of an impact because the people that
watch Fox News will never see it in
other words the reason they haven't
settled which most people are like why
haven't they settled this is very
damaging to them because if they settle
they have to say to their audience
listen we lied to you and they probably
have to say it a hundred times a day but
the point is that they make more money
doing it and they know this
therefore why would they settle they'll
lose 1.6 billion it'll hurt them so
here's the thing the caller is correct
that a lot of you know we asked
yesterday and the day before
are Tucker's viewers going to abandon
Tucker because they're Maga people and
they watch Tucker with the idea that
Trump's going to be praised by Tucker
and now Tucker is exposed in text
messages saying he hates Trump
passionately
Tucker's viewers just won't even hear
about that story because Fox News isn't
covering the story and they only watch
Fox News but there's another aspect of
this even if the caller is right that if
Fox were to settle they might have to do
a Maya culpa and say we were wrong we
lied about this and that
I don't even think their followers would
care about that I genuinely don't I
think they'd go the liberal media forced
him to do it the liberal establishment
forced him to do it they didn't really
lie they told the truth so I actually
think the caller is wrong in that
particular sense let me know what you
think we've got a great bonus show for
you today sign up at joinpakman.com
don't miss it
foreign